[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for a long time as other corners of our
kingdom have stirred the Welsh dragon
Welsh separatism has remained asleep but
little noticed beyond these hills and
mountains its voice is getting louder
[Music]
slowly in halls and meeting rooms and
town squares across this ancient country
an old group which for years has rested
at the fringe has new life we dig well
Nevada series of recent poll says
support for Welsh independence is
growing in Welsh speaking areas like
this yes but even in the
english-speaking South Wales it's gonna
gather together England so it's going to
be in Scotland may be reunified Ireland
then you're gonna have like four
nationalists brexit has provided a
golden opportunity to transform all
weaknesses into strengths it's British
it's the British political institutions
that seem backward looking inward
looking insular the kind of charges that
were made in the past against Welsh
nationalism can now be applied at the
British stage and people see that
actually Welsh independence could be hid
away of Wales joining in with the rest
of the world and becoming a much more
modern inclusive diverse country like uh
Murray is hoping to ride this
slow-moving wave in this election taking
new seats holding marginal ones like
often Wales narrowly voted for breakfast
but Westminster's inability to digest it
has changed wants differential attitudes
towards the British state you're seeing
these scenes on TV of MPs bickering in
the most childish way and I think people
that people in ways Wales Scotland
uneven in England and Northern Ireland's
well just losing faith with the whole
system I think it is yeah
[Music]
Welsh nationalism was always centered on
cultural questions around language
that's changing at the corner maybe
enquire even English singers now say
that support independent something they
wouldn't have done only a few years ago
for reasons this general election
exemplifies it's like when you're in a
quiet you like part of you know
something bigger than yourself and this
election seems to be about going smaller
than yourself if you know what I mean
Welsh independence is unlikely to be
just around the corner but the tectonic
plates of the United Kingdom are
shifting more and more it just feels as
if in each of our countries we're
singing a different song Lewis Caroll's
can use in kanava
[Music]